This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It started with a place called the Stonewall Inn. Gay bars had been rated by police for decades. Gay, lesbian, bisexual, and transgender people had been routinely arrested and subjected to harassment and beatings by the people who were meant to protect them. But one night in this place called the Stonewall Inn, when the police stormed in to continue their abuse, the clientele fought back. The uprising that night, led by drag queens, turned into a protest over the next few days and evolved into a movement that is still making the world better for everyone today.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。这一切始于一个叫做石墙酒吧的地方。几十年来，同性恋酒吧一直遭到警察的突击搜查。男同性恋、女同性恋、双性恋和跨性别者经常遭到本应保护他们的人的逮捕、骚扰和殴打。但在石墙酒吧的那个夜晚，当警察冲进来继续他们的虐待时，顾客们进行了反击。当晚由变装皇后领导的起义在接下来的几天里演变成了一场抗议活动，并演变成了一场直到今天仍在为每个人创造更美好世界的运动。
And it started with a place. On June 28, 1969, the patrons at the Stonewall Inn made history, which is why gay pride celebrations all over the country take place in June. And on June 27, 2016, President Obama and the National Park Service designated the Stonewall Inn, Christopher Park and the surrounding streets as the first national monument to LGBTQ rights. In 1989, 20 years after the Stonewall uprising and now nearly 30 years ago, radio producer Dave Isay created the first documentary of Stonewall ever in any medium. It was also Dave's first radio story, if you can believe it. He later went on to found the much beloved and hugely popular story core project.
这一切始于一个地方。1969年6月28日，石墙酒吧的顾客创造了历史，这就是为什么全国各地的同性恋自豪日庆祝活动都在六月举行。2016年6月27日，奥巴马总统和美国国家公园管理局将石墙酒吧、克里斯托弗公园及周边街道指定为第一个 LGBTQ 权利国家纪念碑。1989年，即石墙起义20年后的今天（现在已经是近30年前），广播制作人戴夫·伊赛创作了历史上第一部关于石墙的任何媒介的纪录片。如果你敢相信的话，这也是戴夫的第一个广播故事。他后来创立了深受喜爱且广受欢迎的 StoryCorps 项目。
With the anniversary and national commemoration of the Stonewall Inn and the tragic massacre in Orlando, I thought it would be good to revisit this place, which, like so many other gay bars around the world, is much more than just a place. This is Remembrance Stonewall by Dave I.C. with Michael Scherker, originally broadcast in 1989. I am Jean Harwood and my age is 80. I'm Bruce Marrow. I don't know if it's really true, but now people do refer to us as the two oldest gay men in America, we do, I think, have maybe a record relationship of almost 60 years
随着石墙酒吧的周年纪念和全国纪念活动以及奥兰多悲惨的大屠杀，我认为重新审视这个地方是个好主意，就像世界各地的许多其他同性恋酒吧一样，它不仅仅是一个地方。这是戴夫·伊赛与迈克尔·谢克尔于 1989 年首播的《铭记石墙》。我是吉恩·哈伍德，我今年 80 岁。我是布鲁斯·莫罗。我不知道这是否属实，但现在人们确实把我们称为美国最年长的两名同性恋男子，我们确实认为，我们拥有近 60 年的记录关系
together. Being gay before a Stonewall was a very difficult proposition because we felt that in order to survive, we had to try to look and act as rugged and manly as possible to get by in the society that was really very much against us. My name is Randy Wicker. I was the first openly gay person to appear on radio in 1962 and on television in 1964 as a self-identified homosexual. In the year before Stonewall, people felt a need to hide because of the precarious legal position they were in. They would lose their jobs. There was a great hostility, socially speaking, in a sense of people found out you were gay. They assumed you were a communist or a child molester or any of another dozen stereotypes
在一起。在石墙事件之前，身为同性恋是一个非常困难的命题，因为我们觉得为了生存，我们必须尽量让自己看起来尽可能粗犷和有男子气概，以便在那个非常反对我们的社会中生存下去。我叫兰迪·威克尔。1962年，我是第一个在广播中公开自己是同性恋身份的人，1964年，我是第一个在电视上公开自己是同性恋身份的人。在石墙事件发生前的一年里，人们因为自己处于不稳定的法律地位而感到有必要隐藏自己。他们会失去工作。社会上存在着巨大的敌意，从某种意义上说，如果人们发现你是同性恋。他们会认为你是共产主义者、恋童癖者或当时在公共媒体上猖獗的数十种刻板印象之一
that were rampant in the public media at the time. I'm Jerry Fair and I'm 80 years old. I started a gay lifestyle in 1948 when I was around 39 or 40. At that time, if there was even a suspicion that you were a lesbian, you were fired from your job, and you were in such a position of disgrace that you slunk out without saying goodbye even to the people that like you and you like, never even bothered to clean your desk. You just disappeared. You just disappeared. You went quietly because you were afraid that the recriminations that would come if you even stood there protested would be worse than just leaving. My name is Sylvia Rivera. My name before that was Brave Rivera until I started dressing
我是杰里·费尔，今年 80 岁。我在 1948 年左右、39 或 40 岁时开始了同性恋的生活方式。当时，哪怕有一点点你可能是女同性恋的嫌疑，你就会被解雇，并且你会处于如此耻辱的境地，以至于你悄悄溜走，甚至都不跟那些喜欢你、你喜欢的人说再见，甚至懒得清理你的办公桌。你只是消失了。你只是消失了。你悄悄地走了，因为你害怕如果你站在那里抗议，随之而来的报复会比离开更糟糕。我叫西尔维娅·里维拉。在此之前我的名字叫布雷夫·里维拉，直到1961年我开始穿
in drag in 1961. There are before Snowmore was a hard-earner. There was always the gay bashings on the drag queens by peddlesexual men, women, and the police. We learned to live with it because it was part of the life style at that time, I guess. But none of us were very happy about it. My name is Simo Pine. In 1968, I was assigned as Deputy Inspector and Charge of Public Morals in the first division in the police department which covered the Greenwich Village area. It was the duty of public morals to enforce or laws concerning
女装。斯诺莫尔之前是一个辛苦赚来的地方。变装皇后总是遭到恋同性恋的男女和警察的殴打。我想我们学会了忍受它，因为那是当时生活方式的一部分。但我们谁对此都不太高兴。我叫西莫·派恩。1968年，我被派往警察局第一分局担任副督察，负责公共道德工作，该分局涵盖格林威治村地区。公共道德的职责是执行有关
vice and gambling, including prostitution, narcotics, and laws and regulations concerning homosexuality. The part of the penal code which applied to drag queens was section 240.35, section 4. Being masked or in any manner disguised by unusual or unnatural attire or facial alteration, loiter's, remains or congregates in a public place. At that time we looked at the Aristotel. We sit around, just try to figure out when this harassment would come to an end. And we would always dream that one day it would come to an end and we prayed and we looked for it Wanted to be human beings
恶习和赌博的法律，包括卖淫、麻醉品以及有关同性恋的法律和法规。适用于变装皇后的刑法部分是第 240.35 条第 4 款。戴着面具或以任何方式用不寻常或不自然的服装或面部改变进行伪装，在公共场所游荡、逗留或聚集。当时我们看着亚里士多德。我们坐在一起，只是试图弄清楚这种骚扰何时才能结束。我们总是梦想着有一天它会结束，我们祈祷并寻找它 想要成为人类
My name is Red Mahoney I've been hanging out drinking party and and working and the gay boys for the last 30 years In the era before a stone wall all all before Stonewall, all of the boys, 90% of the boys were mafia controlled. There wasn't that many gay boys. It had maybe one, two uptown and the upree side. They would get closed down and they'd be one or two on the west side, they'd get closed down
我叫雷德·马霍尼，在过去的 30 年里，我一直和同性恋男孩们一起闲逛、喝酒、聚会和工作。在石墙事件之前，所有男孩中，90%的男孩都是黑手党控制的。没有那么多同性恋男孩。在上城和上东区可能有一两个。他们会被查封，西区也有一两个，会被查封
and midtown they'd be one, two, three, maybe open, as they would get closed down, they'd move around and they would dumps. I'm Joan Nessel, co-founder of what is now the largest collection of lesbian culture in the world. The police raided lesbian bars regularly and they did it, they both did it in the most obvious way, which was hauling women away in patty wagons, but they did, there was regular weak enterasement, which would consist of the police coming in regularly to get their payoffs. And in the Seacone, we had a back room with a red light.
在市中心，可能会有一、两个、三个开着的，随着它们被查封，它们会四处搬迁，变成垃圾场。我是琼·内塞尔，现在是全球最大的女同性恋文化收藏馆的联合创始人。警察经常突击搜查女同性恋酒吧，他们这样做，他们都以最明显的方式这样做，即用囚车把女人拉走，但他们这样做，有定期的周骚扰，其中将包括警察定期进来拿回扣。在西康，我们有一个带红灯的后房间。
And when that red light went on, it meant the police would be arriving in around 10 minutes. And so we all had to sit down at our tables. And we would be sitting there, almost like school children. And the cops would come in now, depending on who was on, which cop was on. If it was some that really resented the Butch women, who were with many times very beautiful women, we knew were in for it because what would happen is they would start harassing one of these women
当红灯亮起时，意味着警察将在大约 10 分钟内到达。所以我们都必须坐在桌子旁。我们会坐在那里，几乎就像小学生一样。警察会进来，现在取决于谁当班，哪个警察当班。如果有些人真的很恨那些经常是非常漂亮的女人的男人婆，我们知道我们要倒霉了，因为会发生什么，他们会开始骚扰其中一个女人
and saying, hi, you think your man come outside will show you and the woman would be dragged away, they throw up against a wall and they'd say, so you think your man, let's see what you've got in your pants and they would put their hand down in a pants. The stone wall, oh that was a good plan, that was. Just to get into the stone wall, you'd walk up and you'd knock on the front door. You'd knock and the door would open and... Hey, what do you want? A Mary sent me, good, come on in girls, you know.
并说，嗨，你认为你的男人出来我们会向你展示，那个女人会被拖走，他们被扔到墙上，他们会说，所以你认为你的男人，让我们看看你的裤子里有什么，他们会把手伸进裤子里。石墙，哦，那是个好计划，那是。要进入石墙，你走过去敲前门。你敲门，门就会打开……嘿，你想干嘛？玛丽派我来的，很好，姑娘们，请进，你知道的。
The stone wall, like all gay boys at that time, were painted black. Chuck-hole black. And what was the funny part? The place would be so dimly lit. But as soon as the cops are going to come in to collect their percentage or whatever they were coming in for, from it being a nice dimly lit dump, the place was lit up like Luna Park. You felt, wow, two guys, and that's very often all we sent in would be two men could handle 200 people. I mean, you tell them to leave and they leave and you say, show me your identification and they all take out their identification and file out and that's it and you say,
石墙，和当时所有的同性恋男孩一样，被漆成了黑色。煤渣黑。有趣的部分是什么？这个地方光线很暗。但一旦警察进来收受百分之成数或他们为之而来的任何东西，原本昏暗的垃圾场就会变得灯火通明，就像月神公园一样。你觉得，哇，两个人，而且通常我们派出的也就是两个人就能应付 200 人。我的意思是，你叫他们离开，他们就离开，你说，出示你的身份证，他们都掏出身份证排队走出去，就是这样，你说，
okay, you're not a man, you're a woman or your vice versa and you wait over there. I mean this is a kind of power that you have and you never gave it a second thought. The drag queen took a lot of oppression and we had to... we were at a point where I guess nothing would have stopped us. I guess as they say, or as Shakespeare says, we were ladies waiting, just waiting for the thing to happen. And when it did happen, we were there. On Friday evening of June 27, 1969, at about 1145, eight officers from New York City's public moral squad loaded into four unmarked police cars and headed to the Stonewall
好吧，你不是男人，你是女人，或者反过来，你在那边等着。我的意思是，这是你拥有的一种权力，你从来没有多想过。变装皇后承受了很大的压迫，我们不得不……我们到了一个我想没有什么能阻止我们的地步。我想正如他们所说，或者正如莎士比亚所说，我们是等待的女士，只等待事情发生。当它发生时，我们在那里。1969年6月27日星期五晚上11点45分左右，纽约市公共道德小队的八名官员登上四辆便衣警车，前往石墙
Inn here at Seventh Avenue in Christopher Street. The local precinct had just received a new commanding officer who kicked off his tenure by initiating a series of raids on gay bars. The Stonewall was an inviting target, operated by the Gambino crime family without a liquor license. The dance bar drew a crowd of drag queens, hustlers, and minors. A number of the bars patrons had spent the early part of the day outside the Frank Campbell funeral home, where Judy Garland's funeral was held.
酒吧，就在第七大道和克里斯托弗街交汇处。当地分局刚刚迎来了新任指挥官，他通过对同性恋酒吧发起一系列突击搜查来开启他的任期。石墙是一个引人注目的目标，由甘比诺犯罪家族经营，没有酒牌。这家舞厅吸引了一群变装皇后、男妓和未成年人。酒吧的一些常客在白天早些时候度过了弗兰克·坎贝尔殡仪馆外，朱迪·加兰的葬礼在那里举行。
She had died the Sunday before. It was almost precisely at midnight that the moral squad pulled up to the stone while in, led by Deputy Inspector Cymor Pine. There was never any reason to feel that anything of any unusual situation would occur that night. You could actually feel it in the air. You really could. I guess Judy Garley's death just really helped us really hit the fan. For some reason things were different this night. As we were bringing the prisoners out, they were resisting. People started gathering in front of the shepherds where a park right across the street from Stonewall.
她于前一个星期天去世。就在午夜时分，道德小队在副督察西莫·派恩的带领下，驶向了石墙酒吧。没有任何理由觉得那天晚上会发生任何不同寻常的情况。你其实能感觉到空气中弥漫着这种气息。真的可以。我想朱迪·加莱的死真的帮了我们一把。不知何故，今晚事情变得不寻常了。当我们把囚犯带出来时，他们进行了抵抗。人们开始聚集在石墙街对面谢泼德公园前。
People were upset. No, we're not going to go and people started screaming and hollering. One drag queen, as we put her in the car, opened the door on the other side and jumped out. At which time we had to chase that person and he was caught, put back into the car. He made another attempt to get out the same door, the other door. And at that point we had to handcuff the person. From this point on, things really began to get crazy. My name is Robert Rivera, and my nickname is Bertie, and I think crust dressing all of my life.
人们很沮丧。不，我们不会走，人们开始尖叫和喊叫。当我们将她塞进车里时，一个变装皇后打开另一侧的车门跳了出去。当时我们不得不追赶那个人，他被抓住后又被塞回车里。他试图从同一扇门、另一扇门再次逃跑。当时我们不得不给这个人戴上手铐。从这一刻起，事情真的开始变得疯狂了。我叫罗伯特·里维拉，我的昵称是伯蒂，我想我一生都在穿裙子。
I remember the night of the riots, the police were escorting the queens out of the bar and into the paddy wagon. And there was this one particularly outrageously beautiful queen, stacks and stacks of liberty-style, with a distale-style hair. And she was asking them not to push her and they continued to push her and she turned around and she mashed the cop with her high heel She knocked him down and then she proceeded to frisk him for her the keys to the handcuffs that were on him
我记得暴动的那天晚上，警察护送王后们出酒吧，送上囚车。其中有一个特别惊艳美丽的皇后，一堆堆的自由风格，留着迪斯黛尔风格的发型。她请求他们不要推她，但他们继续推她，她转过身来，用高跟鞋狠狠地砸了警察一下，把他击倒在地，然后她开始搜他的身，寻找他身上的手铐钥匙
She got them and she ended herself and passed them to another queen that was behind her Well, that's when ball held up. And then we were, we had to get back into the stone wall. My name is Howard Smith. On the night of the Stonewall riots, I was reported for the village boys locked inside with the police covering it for my column. It really did appear that that crowd, because we could look for little peep holes in the plywood windows, we could look out, and we could
她拿到了钥匙，解开自己的手铐，并把它递给身后的另一个皇后。好吧，就在那时，石墙支撑不住了。然后我们不得不退回石墙里面。我叫霍华德·SMITH。在石墙暴动的那晚，我因为报道村里的男孩们被锁在里面而闻名，警察为我的专栏掩护。看起来确实是那样，因为我们可以透过胶合板窗户上的小窥视孔往外看，我们可以看到
see that the crowd, while my guess was within 5-10 minutes, it was probably several thousand people, two to two thousand music, and they were yelling, kill the cops, police brutality, let's get them, we're not going to take this anymore. Let's get out of this group of persons attempting to uproot one of the parking meters in which they did succeed. And they then used that parking meter as a battering ram to break down the door. And they did in fact open the door, they crashed it in. And at that point was when they began throwing Molotov cocktails into the place. It was a situation that we didn't know how we were going to be able to. I remember someone throwing a Molotov cocktail, I don't know who the person was, but I mean, I saw that and I just said to myself in Spanish, I said, oh my God, the revolution is finally
人群，虽然我猜在5-10分钟内，可能达到了几千人，两到两千人，他们在大喊大叫：杀死警察，警察暴力，抓住他们，我们再也不忍受了。让我们摆脱这群试图连根拔起其中一个停车计时器的人，他们确实成功了。然后他们用那个停车计时器作为攻城锤来砸门。他们确实打开了门，把它砸开了。就在那时，他们开始向里面扔莫洛托夫鸡尾酒。当时的情况是我们不知道该怎么应对。我记得有人扔了莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，我不知道那个人是谁，但我的意思是，我看到了，我只是用西班牙语对自己说，我对自己说，天哪，革命终于
here. I just started screaming, freedom. We're free at last, dude, I felt really good. There were a couple of cops stationed on the side of the door with the pistols, like in a combat stand, it's aimed in the door area. A couple others were stationed in other places, behind like a pole, another one behind the bar. All of them were the guns ready. I don't think up to that point I ever had ever seen cops that scared. Remember these were pros that everybody was frightened.
来了。我只是开始尖叫，自由。我们终于自由了，伙计，我感觉真好。门的一侧驻扎着几个警察，手里拿着手枪，就像在战斗姿态一样，瞄准着门口区域。还有几个人驻扎在其他地方，比如一根柱子后面，另一个在酒吧后面。他们都准备好了枪。我不认为在那之前我曾见过如此害怕的警察。记住，这些都是专业人士，每个人都很害怕。
There was no question about that. I know I was frightened. And I'd been in combat situations. And there was never any time that I felt more scared than I felt that moment. And... that I felt more scared than I felt that moment. And, I mean, there was just, you know, there was no place to run. Once the tactical police force showed up, I think I really inc us a little bit more. My name is Martin Boyz. In 1969 I was a drag queen known as Miss Mark. I remember on that night when we saw the riot police, all of us drag queens with link
毫无疑问。我知道我很害怕。而且我经历过战斗情况。从来没有哪个时刻让我感到比那一刻更害怕。而且……让我觉得比那一刻更害怕。而且，我的意思是，你知道，根本无处可逃。一旦防暴警察出现，我认为这真的激怒了我们更多。我叫马丁·博伊斯。1969年，我是一个被称为“马克小姐”的变装皇后。我记得在那天晚上，当我们看到防暴警察时，我们所有的变装皇后都手挽着手
to arms, lighted our heads and sang the song we used to sing. We are the village girls. We wear our hands and girls. We wear our dungaries, our above our nailing knees, and the police went crazy hearing that and they just immediately rushed us. We gave one kick and three. My name is Rudy and the night of the storm while I was 18 and to tell you this truth that night I was doing more running than fighting. I remember looking back from Tenth Street and there on Waverly Street there was a police I believe on his cop and his on his stomach in his tactical uniform and his helmet and
抬起头，唱起了我们过去常唱的歌。我们是村里的姑娘。我们穿着双手和姑娘们。我们穿着粗斜纹棉布裤，裤腿在膝盖以上，警察听到这个都疯了，立刻冲了过来。我们踢了一脚，三下。我叫鲁迪，风暴之夜我18岁，说实话，那天晚上我跑步的时间比打架的时间多。我记得从十街回头看，在沃弗利街上，我看到一个警察，我相信是他的一个警官，趴在地上，穿着防暴制服、头盔和
everything else with a drag queen straddling him. She was beating the hell out of him with her shoe whether it was a high heel or not I don't know but she was beaten the hell out of them It was hysterical My name is mama Jean I'm a lesbian. I remember on that night. I was in the gay bar a woman's bar called cookies We were coming out of the gay bar going towards aid street and That's when we saw everything happen blasting Blasting away, people getting beat up. Please come from every direction.
其他一切，上面骑着一个变装皇后。她用鞋子狠狠地揍了他，是不是高跟鞋我不知道，但她狠狠地揍了他，太疯狂了。我叫妈妈让，我是个女同性恋。我记得那天晚上。我在一个名叫饼干的女同性恋酒吧里。我们从同性恋酒吧出来，走向第八街，就在那时我们看到一切都在发生：爆炸、爆炸，人们被打。警察从四面八方赶来。
Hitting women, as well as men with their night sticks. Game men running down the street with blood all over their face. We decided right then and there whether we scared or not, we didn't think about it. We just jumped in. Here, the screen is going completely bananas, you know, jumping and hitting the windshield. And next thing you know, it attacks the cabers, being turned over. Other cars would be in turned over. When those were shattering all over the place, wires were burning around the place.
用警棍殴打妇女和男子。同性恋男子满脸鲜血地跑过街头。我们当即决定，不管害不害怕，我们根本没多想。我们直接冲了进去。在这里，屏幕彻底疯了，你知道的，跳起来砸挡风玻璃。接下来你知道的，出租车被翻了个底朝天。其他汽车也被翻倒了。玻璃碎片四处飞溅，电线在周围燃烧。
It was beautiful. It really was. It was really beautiful. I remember one cop coming at me, hitting me with the night stick in the back of my legs. I broke loose and I went after him. I grabbed his night stick. My girlfriend went behind him. She was a strong servant again. I wanted to feel the same pain I felt. And I kept them saying to him, how do you like the pain? Do you like it? Do you like it? I kept them hitting them and hitting them. I was angry. I wanted to the kill him. At that particular minute I went to kill him. I wanted to do every destructive thing that I could think of at that time to hurt anyone that had hurt us through the years.
太美了。真的。真的很美。我记得一个警察朝我走来，用警棍击打我的小腿后部。我挣脱了，然后追了上去。我抓住他的警棍。我的女友跟在他身后。她又是一个坚强的仆人。我想感受我感受过的同样的痛苦。我一直对他说，你觉得这痛苦怎么样？你喜欢吗？你喜欢吗？我一直在打他，不停地打他。我很生气。我想杀了他。在那一分钟里，我想杀了他。我想做我能想到的所有最具破坏性的事情，去伤害那些多年来伤害过我们的人。
It's like just when you see a man protecting his own life. They weren't the queens that people called him. They were men fighting for their lives. And I'd fight alongside them any day, no matter how old I was. There were a lot of heads were bashed. There's not much of a people there. But it didn't hurt their true feelings.
这就像你看到一个男人在保护自己的生命一样。他们不是人们口中的皇后。他们是为生命而战的男人。无论我多大年纪，我都愿意随时与他们并肩作战。许多人的脑袋被打得稀巴烂。那里没多少人。但这并没有伤害他们真实的情感。
They all came back from real. And nothing, that's when you could tell that nothing could stop us at that time, at any time in the future. I'll be loving you. every time I'm all again. The riots were well covered in the media. The New York Daily News featured it on the front page. There were reports on all of the local television and radio stations. By the next day, graffiti calling for gay power had started to show up all over the West
他们全都从真实中走了出来。没有什么，那就是你可以看出当时没有任何东西、将来任何时候也没有任何东西能阻止我们。我将永远爱你。每一次我都将再次……暴动在媒体上得到了充分报道。《纽约每日新闻》将其登在头版。所有本地电视台和广播电台都有相关报道。到了第二天，要求同性恋力量的涂鸦开始出现在西村的各处
Village. The next night, thousands of men and women came back to the Stonewall to see what would happen next. While a couple of trash cans were set on fire and some stones were thrown, the 400 riot police, milling around outside the bar, ensured that the previous evening's violence would not be repeated. But on this night gay couples could be spotted walking hand in hand and kissing in the streets. Just by being at the Stonewall, surrounded by reporters, photographers, and onlookers, thousands of men and women were proclaiming that they were gay.
第二天晚上，成千上万的男女回到石墙酒吧，看接下来会发生什么。虽然有几个垃圾桶被点燃，还扔了一些石头，但聚集在酒吧外面的400名防暴警察确保了前一晚的暴力事件不会重演。但在这个晚上，可以看到同性恋情侣手挽着手在街上散步和亲吻。仅仅通过出现在石墙，被记者、摄影师和旁观者包围，成千上万的男女就在宣告他们是同性恋。
The crowds grew and came back the next night night and for one more night the following week. What happened at the Stonewall on those nights helped usher in a new era for gay men and lesbians. When Stonewall happened, Bruce and I were still in the closet, where we had been for nearly 40 years. But we realized that this was a tremendous thing that had happened at Stonewall and it gave us a feeling that we were not going to be remaining closeted for very much longer. And soon thereafter we did come out of the closet. So, in 1969 I was in the Convent, and when Stonewall hit the press, it hit me with a bolt of lightning.
人群不断聚集，并在第二天晚上以及接下来的一周又回来了一晚。那些夜晚在石墙发生的事情开启了男同性恋和女同性恋的新纪元。石墙事件发生时，布鲁斯和我仍然在柜子里，我们在那里呆了近 40 年。但我们意识到石墙发生了一件了不起的事情，它给我们一种感觉，我们不会在柜子里呆太久了。不久之后，我们确实走出了柜子。所以，1969 年我在修道院里，当石墙冲上媒体时，它就像一道闪电一样击中了。
It was as if I had an incredible release of my own outrage at having to sequester so much of my life. I made my way down. I seemed to recall in subsequent nights being down on the, you know, kind of just in the periphery looking observer, clearly an observer, clearly longing to have that courage to come out. And it was a matter, as I recall, it was only a matter of weeks before I left the convent and started a new life. I'm Henry Beard. In 1969, I was in the US Army, a specialist three stationed at Long Bend Post near Saigon in Vietnam.
就好像我对不得不将我生命中如此之多的一部分隐匿起来的愤怒得到了极大的释放。我向下走去。我依稀记得在接下来的几个夜里，在边缘地带，你知道的，就只是在边缘看着的观察者，显然是个观察者，显然渴望有那种出柜的勇气。正如我所记起的，那只是几个星期的事情，我就离开了修道院，开始了新的生活。我是亨利·贝尔德。1969年，我在美国陆军，是一名三级专家，驻扎在越南西贡附近的隆本哨所。
I remember I was having lunch in the Army mess, reading the Armed Forces' new summary of the day. And there was a short paragraph describing a riot led by homosexuals and Greenwich Village against the police. And my heart was filled with joy. I thought about what I had read frequently, but I had no one to discuss it with. And secretly within myself I decided that when I came back state-side, if I should, survived to come back state-side, I would come out as a gay person and I did.
我记得我当时在陆军食堂吃午饭，阅读武装部队当天的简报。上面有一小段文字，描述了格林威治村的同性恋者领导的一场针对警察的暴动。我的心中充满了喜悦。我经常回想我读到的内容，但我没有人可以讨论它。我内心深处秘密决定，当我回到美国本土时，如果我能幸存下来回到美国本土，我会以同性恋者的身份出柜，我确实这么做了。
For those of us in public morals after the Stonewall incident things were completely changed from what they had previously been. They suddenly were not submissive anymore. They now suddenly had gained a new type of courage. And it seemed as if they didn't care anymore about whether their identities were made known. We were now dealing with human beings. Today I live in a senior citizen apartment building. What's different now is that I can be free. I have a daughter who's a senior citizen and my son is 58. They
对于我们这些在石墙事件后从事公共道德工作的人来说，情况与以前完全不同了。他们突然不再顺从了。他们现在突然获得了另一种勇气。而且看起来他们不再在乎自己的身份是否为人所知。我们现在打交道的是活生生的人。今天我住在老年人公寓楼里。现在不同的是我可以自由了。我有一个当高级公民的女儿，我儿子58岁。他们
know about my homosexuality. My three grandchildren in the thirties know about their grandmother. I have a great granddaughter who at the age of ten learned that grandma Jerry was a lesbian and she thought that was most interesting and yet I still don't have the personal courage to not care if these yanders in the building know that Jerry's a lesbian. Well, I retired from the police department in 1976. 20 years have passed. I'm going to be 17 in a few months. I still don't know the answers.
知道我的同性恋倾向。我三十多岁的三个孙子知道他们的奶奶。我有一个曾孙女，十岁时得知奶奶杰瑞是个女同性恋，她觉得这非常有趣，然而我仍然没有个人勇气不在乎楼里的这些扬德尔人知道杰瑞是个女同性恋。好吧，我在 1976 年从警察局退休。20 年过去了。几个月后我就满 17 岁了。我还是不知道答案。
I would still like to know the answer. I would like to know whether I was wrong, or whether I was right, in ever thinking that there was a difference, in ever thinking that maybe you shouldn't trust a homosexual because something is missing in his personality. The archives of lesbian culture which surrounds us now and was created four years after Stonewall owes at least from my part its creation to that night in the courage that found its voice in the streets. That night, in some very deep way, we finally found our place in history. Not as a dirty joke, not as a doctor's case study not as a freak but as a people.
我仍然想知道答案。我想知道我是否错了，或者我是对的，曾经认为存在差异，曾经认为也许你不应该信任同性恋者，因为他的个性中缺少了某些东西。现在包围着我们的、在石墙事件四年后建立的女同性恋文化档案馆，至少从我这部分来说，它的诞生要归功于那个夜晚以及在街头找到声音的勇气。那个夜晚，在某种非常深邃的方式中，我们终于找到了我们在历史上的位置。不是作为恶俗的笑话，不是作为医生的病例研究，不是作为怪胎，而是作为一个群体。
Today I'm a 38-year-old drag queen. I can keep my long hair, I can pluck my eyebrows and I can work wherever the hell I want and I'm not going to change for anybody. If I change, then I feel that I'm losing what 1969 brought into my life. And that was to be totally free. ever call the door and be the same as I was before. No, I can't anymore It's true, very long Remembering Stonewall was produced by Dave Isay with Michael Scherker in 1989. This documentary was a production of Sound Portraits, which went on to spawn StoryCore, which is dedicated to collecting, sharing, and preserving people's stories from around the world. You might have heard story core on the radio, but their podcast, which is hosted by their producers, offers longer stories that go more in depth and offer more back story.
今天我是一个 38 岁的变装皇后。我可以留长发，修眉毛，想去哪工作就去哪工作，我不会为任何人改变。如果我改变了，那么我觉得我正在失去 1969 年带给我生活的东西。那就是彻底的自由。永远呼唤大门，和以前一样。不，我再也不能了。这是真的，非常长久。《铭记石墙》由戴夫·伊赛与迈克尔·谢克尔于 1989 年制作。这部纪录片是 Sound Portraits 的作品，后来催生了 StoryCorps，后者致力于收集、分享和保护来自世界各地人们的故事。你可能在广播中听过 StoryCorps，但他们的播客由制作人主持，提供了更长、更深入的故事和更多的背景故事。
It's even better than it is on the radio. You can get it and get more information about story core at storycore.org. 99% Invisible is Sam Green span to Laney Hall, Kurt Colessted, Katie Mingle, Avery, Truffleman, Sharif, Yousef, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interior's firm. In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow us all on Twitter and you. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它甚至比广播里的还要好。你可以在 storycore.org 上获取它以及有关 StoryCorps 的更多信息。99% Invisible 的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘、拉尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、凯蒂·明格、艾瑞费·特鲁夫曼、谢里夫·优素福以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是加州旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑与室内设计公司 Arxine 的办公室制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并喜欢这个节目，你可以在 Twitter 上关注我们所有人。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。